look around you
what makes you believe you're not just a
weapon
to achieve his end enough
[Music]
join our cause or be made
to serve right now
you hold all the power
make your choice sylvanas windrunner
despite all our efforts
the mall continues to grow
what if dinathius denathrius's treachery
is irreparable
the primus is lost and bastion cannot
save the shadowlands alone
none of this should have happened
perhaps the winter queen could
my archon a living soul
seeks an audience a mortal
a king
by all our measures one who has spent
his life
striving for justice
one who would give anything to serve
his people
[Music]
one whose heart is true
very well he may approach
step forward
[Music]
my ascended have spoken of you
the king held captive in the mall
prison could not hold me forever
why have you come to bastion
you have a key that i need
[Music]
you will release this soul from your
grasp
no he is bound to me
just as you would sought to buy
your own brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the vessel performed its part
flawlessly
[Music]
three keys
then they will see
death was never meant
to be chained
you